das ist wirklich der wahnsinn die
stärkste je gemessene gravitationswellen
wurde jetzt entdeckt arbeit einstein hat
gravitationswellen ja bereits im jahr
1916 vorhergesagt doch erst ganze 100
jahre später konnten sie dann erstmals
nachgewiesen werden wellen die entstehen
wenn die raumzeit durch ein kurzes
gravitations ereignis gekrümmt wird und
von dort aus wellen der raumzeit
krümmung ausgehen und seit der
entdeckung der ersten gravitationswellen
2015 entwickelt sich daraus eine neue
disziplin die gravitationswellen
astronomie entdeckt wurde jetzt eine
neue gravitationswellen die absolut
rekordverdächtig ist die massereichste
und am weitesten entfernteste
gravitationswellen klicks um
science-fiction nur hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst er nicht
herzlich willkommen 2017 war es soweit
der nobelpreis für physik ging an drei
amerikanische gravitationswellen
forscher denn sie hatten mit ihren
experimenten und mit ihrer
grundlagenforschung zum ersten mal den
nachweis von gravitationswellen erbracht
rainer weiß gifhorn und barry burns
haben damit auch gezeigt dass einstein
schon vor 100 jahren mit seinen ideen
recht hatte es begann am 14 september
2015 um 551 amerikanischer ortszeit
rainer weis war verreist und lag zu
dieser uhrzeit noch im bett weit weg von
seinen beiden kilometer langen
detektoren die plötzlich erzittert
fehlalarm
nein ganz sicher nicht und das war der
große moment der von jetzt auf gleich
alles veränderte nach jahrzehntelanger
suche hatte man endlich
gravitationswellen gemessen ausgelöst
durch den zusammenstoß von zwei
schwarzen löchern und wie immer in der
wissenschaft ist solch eine entdeckung
noch deutlich mehr wert wenn sie
wiederholt werden kann und tatsächlich
auch folgende messungen bestätigten den
nachhall solcher kollisionen unter
anderem konnten gravitationswellen
detektiert werden deren ursache die
kollision von zwei neutronen stern war
eine sensation für die wissenschaftswelt
allein durch das belauschen der raumzeit
schwingung waren forschungsteams also zu
diesem zeitpunkt in der lage kosmische
phänomene aufzuspüren selbst diejenigen
die keine oder nur wenig
elektromagnetische strahlung freisetzen
das war der wissenschaftswelt
bisher verborgen geblieben damit hatte
eine neue ära der physik begonnen
mittlerweile konnten insgesamt zehn
gravitationswellen ereignisse aufgespürt
werden die durch das verschmelzen von
schwarzen löchern entstanden sind hinzu
kommt die messung des crashs der beiden
neutronensterne die vier aktuelles
neuzugänge wurden in früheren
aufzeichnungen der gravitationswellen
observatorien liga in den usa und
wirkung in italien aufgespürt die
messungen laufen hier in einem
sogenannten interferenz experiment bei
dem ein laserstrahl in zwei teile
strahlen aufgespalten wird die
lichtwellen werden in zwei röhren
geleitet die exakt gleich lang sind und
im rechten winkel zueinander stehen am
ende steht ein spiegel der diese beiden
strahlen reflektiert und zurückwirft
wenn sich die strahlen im normalfall
aufheben also die frequenzen gibt es
kein signal kann jedoch ein signal
gemessen werden liegt dies an einer
gravitationswellen die die raumzeit
verzerrt denn dadurch variiert die länge
der röhren und damit der laserstrahlen
und die haben durch diese wellenartige
krümmung der raumzeit eine laufzeit
verschiebung durch dieses verfahren wird
die tatsächliche krümmung der raumzeit
sichtbar das wirklich ziemlich verrückt
das große problem hierbei ist allerdings
dass die messungen sehr genau sein
müssen da der effekt der
gravitationswellen super super klein ist
wir leben hier die krümmung der raumzeit
ja viel stärker aber eben kontinuierlich
nicht als welle hier auf der erde
verändert sie sich nicht wir werden
durch die durch die erde verursachte
krümmung der raumzeit auf sie gezogen
die gravitation oder umgangssprachlich
erdanziehungskraft ich zeige dass mal
kurz mal wieder zurückgezogen raumzeit
klemmung die aktuellen neuzugängen
jedenfalls entstanden durch die
kollisionen von schwarzen löchern
unter diesen neuzugängen ist auch ein
rekordbrecher konkret geht es um das
neue ereignis namens gw also
gravitätischen wave 17 07 29 die
massereichste und am weitesten entfernte
gravitationsfeld quelle die bislang
überhaupt aufgespürt werden konnte mehr
als 80 sonnenmassen wurden bei dieser
verschmelzung die vor etwa fünf
milliarden jahren stattgefunden hat in
gravitationswellen umgewandelt das war
ein gigantisches ereignis die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
feiern einen weiteren erfolg denn sie
konnten ein weiteres ereignis gw 17 08
so genau lokalisieren wie es zuvor noch
nie gelang hat zu schielen
von der university of glasgow diese
entdeckung zeigen uns wie wertvoll die
gravitationswellen astronomie für unser
verständnis des universums ist wir
warten noch viele weitere spannende
entdeckungen gefeiert werden aber nicht
nur diese beiden neuen einzel
entdeckungen sondern auch dass sich
somit stück für stück ein gesamtbild
zusammen setzt dazu haben sich die
forschungsteams die schwarzen löcher die
sich in doppelsystem umkreisen und dann
verschmelzen genauer angeschaut das
ergebnis sie alle sind wohl aus stern
mit bis zu etwas mehr als 50
sonnenmassen entstanden die schwarzen
löcher die aus dem kollisionen entstehen
haben eine masse von 2,8 bis 80,3
sonnenmassen die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler sind optimistisch
dass in kürze weitere spannende
entdeckungen folgen werden dazu schien
von der university of glasgow
die wissenschaft hat ein jahrhundert
gebraucht um einsteins vorhersage zu
bestätigen
doch das tempo unserer entdeckung hat
sich seitdem enorm beschleunigt ja und
das zeigt die entdeckung von weiteren
ereignissen in den daten der
interferometer und die
gravitationswellen astronomie wird
komplett unsinnig wenn das erste opfer
thorium im weltraum in betrieb genommen
wird leiser wie es heißt wird im
gegensatz zu lego keine arm länge von
vier kilometern für die laserstrahlen
haben sondern von achtung sitzen 2,5
millionen kilometer 2034 wird es soweit
sein
wir werden noch ein wenig warten müssen
dann aber und das verspreche ich werden
hier wir hier auf klicks um ausführlich
darüber berichten wird es unendlich
viele entdeckungen geben lernen kann man
ja nicht nur hierbei klicks um eine
menge sondern seit neuestem auch bei
culcha candela die erklären musik und
ich finde es mega cool hier unbedingt
drauf klicken und unbedingt kommentieren
abonnieren die jungs haben in die hand
versprochen nahezu jeden kommentar
persönlich zu beantworten also bis dann
bleibt dran